del fin visita al hospital cada semana
para su quimioterapia al cáncer se suma
el miedo por el cob y el riesgo de
contagiarse de una forma grave del virus
afectó directamente sus relaciones
sociales desde hace un año limita al
máximo las visitas incluidas las de su
hija de siete años
las dos tenemos miedo de pasarnos el
virus lo derriba así que no vemos a
muchas personas ver o ir a tomar un café
con mis colegas de trabajo eso es lo
extraño demasiado ir al colegio donde
trabajo me lo prohíbe
por eso la vacuna es una esperanza para
nosotros nuestras familias y una forma
de revivir también fue necesario más de
un mes de negociaciones para que las
autoridades de la salud autorizarán a
los médicos especialistas que pedían
vacunar a sus pacientes que siguen un
tratamiento
en el instituto santa caterina de aviñón
están organizando los protocolos lo más
importante es el seguimiento del
paciente se saca o post haremos esto
cuando tengamos un análisis la direcciã
está protegido o te recibo pues en los
enfermos de cáncer la vacuna no tiene un
resultado garantizado estos
especialistas estiman en un 30% la
eficacia del antígeno en pacientes
oncológicos con cepas lo que no sabemos
es si la vacuna va a ser eficaz en un
paciente que por ejemplo está siguiendo
una quimioterapia puede que no funcione
porque la inmunidad que es sometida a
quimioterapia está alterada los
mecanismos que activan las defensas
contra el virus pueden estar alterados
es esa sobre todo la parte menos clara
sus sales son como las vacunas de pfizer
y modernas tienen en promedio un 95 por
ciento de eficacia pero los ensayos
clínicos los pacientes inmunodeprimidos
fueron los grandes olvidados pese a la
incertidumbre del instituto santa
catarina contará con vacunas suficientes
para inocular a todos sus pacientes